Let me tell you a story
about artificial intelligence.
There's a building in Sydney
at 1 Bligh Street.
It houses lots of government apartments
and busy people.
From the outside, it looks like something
out of American science fiction:
all gleaming glass and curved lines,
and a piece of orange sculpture.
On the inside, it has excellent coffee
on the ground floor
and my favorite lifts in Sydney.
They're beautiful;
they look almost alive.
And it turns out
I'm fascinated with lifts.
For lots of reasons.
But because lifts are one of the places
you can see the future.
In the 21st century, lifts are interesting
because they're one of the first places
that AI will touch you
without you even knowing it happened.
In many buildings all around the world,
the lifts are running a set of algorithms.
A form of protoartificial intelligence.
That means before you even
walk up to the lift to press the button,
it's anticipated you being there.
It's already rearranging
all the carriages.
Always going down, to save energy,
and to know where
the traffic is going to be.
By the time you've actually
pressed the button,
you're already part of an entire system
that's making sense of people
and the environment
and the building and the built world.
I know when we talk about AI,
we often talk about a world of robots.
It's easy for our imaginations
to be occupied with science fiction,
well, over the last 100 years.
I say AI and you think "The Terminator."
Somewhere, for us, making the connection
between AI and the built world,
that's a harder story to tell.
But the reality is AI is already
everywhere around us.
And in many places.
It's in buildings and in systems.
More than 200 years of industrialization
suggest that AI will find its way
to systems-level scale relatively easily.
After all, one telling of that history
suggests that all you have to do
is find a technology,
achieve scale and revolution will follow.
The story of mechanization,
automation and digitization
all point to the role of technology
and its importance.
Those stories of technological
transformation
make scale seem, well, normal.
Or expected.
And stable.
And sometimes even predictable.
But it also puts the focus squarely
on technology and technology change.
But I believe that scaling a technology
and building a system
requires something more.
We founded the 3Ai Institute
at the Australian National University
in September 2017.
It has one deceptively simple mission:
to establish a new branch of engineering
to take AI safely, sustainably
and responsibly to scale.
But how do you build a new branch
of engineering in the 21st century?
Well, we're teaching it into existence
through an experimental education program.
We're researching it into existence
with locations as diverse
as Shakespeare's birthplace,
the Great Barrier Reef,
not to mention one of Australia's
largest autonomous mines.
And we're theorizing it into existence,
paying attention to the complexities
of cybernetic systems.
We're working to build something new
and something useful.
Something to create the next generation
of critical thinkers and critical doers.
And we're doing all of that
through a richer understanding
of AI's many pasts and many stories.
And by working collaboratively
and collectively
through teaching and research
and engagement,
and by focusing as much
on the framing of the questions
as the solving of the problems.
We're not making a single AI,
we're making the possibilities for many.
And we're actively working
to decolonize our imaginations
and to build a curriculum and a pedagogy
that leaves room for a range of different
conversations and possibilities.
We are making and remaking.
And I know we're always
a work in progress.
But here's a little glimpse
into how we're approaching
that problem of scaling a future.
We start by making sure
we're grounded in our own history.
In December of 2018,
I took myself up to the town of Brewarrina
on the New South Wales-Queensland border.
This place was a meeting place
for Aboriginal people,
for different groups,
to gather, have ceremonies,
meet, to be together.
There, on the Barwon River,
there's a set of fish weirs
that are one of the oldest
and largest systems
of Aboriginal fish traps in Australia.
This system is comprised
of 1.8 kilometers of stone walls
shaped like a series of fishnets
with the "Us" pointing down the river,
allowing fish to be trapped
at different heights of the water.
They're also fish holding pens
with different-height walls for storage,
designed to change the way the water moves
and to be able to store
big fish and little fish
and to keep those fish
in cool, clear running water.
This fish-trap system was a way to ensure
that you could feed people
as they gathered there in a place
that was both a meeting of rivers
and a meeting of cultures.
It isn't about the rocks
or even the traps per se.
It is about the system
that those traps created.
One that involves technical knowledge,
cultural knowledge
and ecological knowledge.
This system is old.
Some archaeologists
think it's as old as 40,000 years.
The last time we have its recorded uses
is in the nineteen teens.
It's had remarkable longevity
and incredible scale.
And it's an inspiration to me.
And a photo of the weir
is on our walls here at the Institute,
to remind us of the promise
and the challenge
of building something meaningful.
And to remind us
that we're building systems
in a place where people have built systems
and sustained those same systems
for generations.
It isn't just our history,
it's our legacy as we seek to establish
a new branch of engineering.
To build on that legacy
and our sense of purpose,
I think we need a clear framework
for asking questions about the future.
Questions for which there aren't
ready or easy answers.
Here, the point is the asking
of the questions.
We believe you need to go
beyond the traditional approach
of problem-solving,
to the more complicated one
of question asking
and question framing.
Because in so doing, you open up
all kinds of new possibilities
and new challenges.
For me, right now,
there are six big questions
that frame our approach
for taking AI safely, sustainably
and responsibly to scale.
Questions about autonomy,
agency, assurance,
indicators, interfaces and intentionality.
The first question we ask is a simple one.
Is the system autonomous?
Think back to that lift on Bligh Street.
The reality is, one day,
that lift may be autonomous.
Which is to say it will be able
to act without being told to act.
But it isn't fully autonomous, right?
It can't leave that Bligh Street building
and wonder down
to Circular Quay for a beer.
It goes up and down, that's all.
But it does it by itself.
It's autonomous in that sense.
The second question we ask:
does this system have agency?
Does this system have controls
and limits that live somewhere
that prevent it from doing certain
kinds of things under certain conditions.
The reality with lifts,
that's absolutely the case.
Think of any lift you've been in.
There's a red keyslot
in the elevator carriage
that an emergency services person
can stick a key into
and override the whole system.
But what happens
when that system is AI-driven?
Where does the key live?
Is it a physical key, is it a digital key?
Who gets to use it?
Is that the emergency services people?
And how would you know
if that was happening?
How would all of that be manifested
to you in the lift?
The third question we ask
is how do we think about assurance.
How do we think about all of its pieces:
safety, security, trust, risk,
liability, manageability,
explicability, ethics,
public policy, law, regulation?
And how would we tell you
that the system was safe and functioning?
The fourth question we ask
is what would be our interfaces
with these AI-driven systems.
Will we talk to them?
Will they talk to us,
will they talk to each other?
And what will it mean to have
a series of technologies we've known,
for some of us, all our lives,
now suddenly behave
in entirely different ways?
Lifts, cars, the electrical grid,
traffic lights, things in your home.
The fifth question
for these AI-driven systems:
What will the indicators be
to show that they're working well?
Two hundred years
of the industrial revolution
tells us that the two most important ways
to think about a good system
are productivity and efficiency.
In the 21st century,
you might want to expand
that just a little bit.
Is the system sustainable,
is it safe, is it responsible?
Who gets to judge those things for us?
Users of the systems
would want to understand
how these things are regulated,
managed and built.
And then there's the final,
perhaps most critical question
that you need to ask
of these new AI systems.
What's its intent?
What's the system designed to do
and who said that was a good idea?
Or put another way,
what is the world
that this system is building,
how is that world imagined,
and what is its relationship
to the world we live in today?
Who gets to be part of that conversation?
Who gets to articulate it?
How does it get framed and imagined?
There are no simple answers
to these questions.
Instead, they frame what's possible
and what we need to imagine,
design, build, regulate
and even decommission.
They point us in the right directions
and help us on a path to establish
a new branch of engineering.
But critical questions aren't enough.
You also need a way of holding
all those questions together.
For us at the Institute,
we're also really interested
in how to think about AI as a system,
and where and how to draw
the boundaries of that system.
And those feel like especially
important things right now.
Here, we're influenced by the work
that was started way back in the 1940s.
In 1944, along with anthropologists
Gregory Bateson and Margaret Mead,
mathematician Norbert Wiener
convened a series of conversations
that would become known
as the Macy Conferences on Cybernetics.
Ultimately, between 1946 and 1953,
ten conferences were held
under the banner of cybernetics.
As defined by Norbert Wiener,
cybernetics sought
to "develop a language and techniques
that will enable us to indeed attack
the problem of control and communication
in advanced computing technologies."
Cybernetics argued persuasively
that one had to think
about the relationship
between humans, computers
and the broader ecological world.
You had to think about them
as a holistic system.
Participants in the Macy Conferences
were concerned with how the mind worked,
with ideas about
intelligence and learning,
and about the role
of technology in our future.
Sadly, the conversations that started
with the Macy Conference
are often forgotten
when the talk is about AI.
But for me, there's something
really important to reclaim here
about the idea of a system
that has to accommodate culture,
technology and the environment.
At the Institute, that sort
of systems thinking is core to our work.
Over the last three years,
a whole collection of amazing people
have joined me here
on this crazy journey to do this work.
Our staff includes anthropologists,
systems and environmental engineers,
and computer scientists
as well as a nuclear physicist,
an award-winning photo journalist,
and at least one policy
and standards expert.
It's a heady mix.
And the range of experience
and expertise is powerful,
as are the conflicts and the challenges.
Being diverse requires
a constant willingness
to find ways to hold people
in conversation.
And to dwell just a little bit
with the conflict.
We also worked out early
that the way to build
a new way of doing things
would require a commitment to bringing
others along on that same journey with us.
So we opened our doors
to an education program very quickly,
and we launched our first
master's program in 2018.
Since then, we've had two cohorts
of master's students
and one cohort of PhD students.
Our students come from all over the world
and all over life.
Australia, New Zealand, Nigeria, Nepal,
Mexico, India, the United States.
And they range in age from 23 to 60.
They variously had backgrounds
in maths and music,
policy and performance,
systems and standards,
architecture and arts.
Before they joined us at the Institute,
they ran companies,
they worked for government,
served in the army, taught high school,
and managed arts organizations.
They were adventurers
and committed to each other,
and to building something new.
And really, what more could you ask for?
Because although I've spent
20 years in Silicon Valley
and I know the stories
about the lone inventor
and the hero's journey,
I also know the reality.
That it's never just a hero's journey.
It's always a collection of people
who have a shared sense of purpose
who can change the world.
So where do you start?
Well, I think you start where you stand.
And for me, that means
I want to acknowledge
the traditional owners of the land
upon which I'm standing.
The Ngunnawal and Ngambri people,
this is their land,
never ceded, always sacred.
And I pay my respects to the elders,
past and present, of this place.
I also acknowledge
that we're gathering today
in many other places,
and I pay my respects
to the traditional owners and elders
of all those places too.
It means a lot to me
to get to say those words
and to dwell on what they mean and signal.
And to remember that we live in a country
that has been continuously occupied
for at least 60,000 years.
Aboriginal people built worlds here,
they built social systems,
they built technologies.
They built ways to manage this place
and to manage it remarkably
over a protracted period of time.
And every moment any one of us
stands on a stage as Australians,
here or abroad,
we carry with us a privilege
and a responsibility
because of that history.
And it's not just a history.
It's also an incredibly rich
set of resources,
worldviews and knowledge.
And it should run through all of our bones
and it should be the story we always tell.
Ultimately, it's about
thinking differently,
asking different kinds of questions,
looking holistically
at the world and the systems,
and finding other people who want
to be on that journey with you.
Because for me,
the only way to actually think
about the future and scale
is to always be doing it collectively.
And because for me,
the notion of humans in it together
is one of the ways
we get to think about things
that are responsible, safe
and ultimately, sustainable.
Thank you.